on va voir si guy bedos et gaulliste je
ne suis pas un gaulliste est pas
gaulliste
non je juge fit d'ailleurs je crois le
seul ici à ne pas avoir fréquenté
assidûment du général de gaulle c'est
peut-être que je suis le plus jeune
aussi
oui et puis d'autres raisons alors guy
bedos publié chez calmann-lévy une
autobiographie clé je craque
trois points qui t'avait pas me demander
de raconter de livres alors je vois
votre part levé dans l'armée de vie même
si j'avais su j'aurais pas écrit mais
sinon je vais pas le mal aimé c'est une
chose que je vous demanderai pas en tout
cas c'est
la page 10 vous écrivez les femmes c'est
comme les pommes de terre pour que ça
saute
c'est vrai là bas je vous demanderai pas
de la fois que j'ai incarné un écrivain
salon c'était dans un sketch mettant des
tout de même pourquoi vous écrivez je me
sens tout de même plus proche d'albert
camus que d'un haricot macias parce que
ça vous l'écrivez oui c'est vrai je
dirais que oui bah c'est peut-être parce
que c'est vrai c'est à dire que oui je
veux dire je suis pieds noirs
j'ai effectivement intitulé un des
chapitres de ce livre blackfoot
flashback ce qui est des jeux de mots
très amusant au niveau de la phonétique
pour ceux qui comprennent l'anglais
je laisse ça nous a fait rire parce que
vous vous comprenez très bien l'anglais
mais je vous ai pas vu rire vous avez un
don de dieu m'a mis là vous ne regardiez
pas les vues sourire il s'agit bleu gris
très gaulliste
bon alors je raconte je raconte mon
équipier noir cette rivière de
pieds-noirs vous même bruit alors oui tu
puisses tu es noir et rouge mois annoncé
la couleur
oui alors vous vous parlez d'une prise
de conscience politique à l'âge de 8 ans
oui alors vous allez me demander de
raconter malienne dans le lion parce que
moi je l'écouté et très franchement j'ai
été étonné parce que je savais pas que
vous aviez cette politique est bon je
vais danser mais j'avais découvert
quelques temps auparavant parce que vous
veniez que j'investis paie pas du tout à
quoi mais non simplement vous étiez
devenu militant politique parce que
j'ai vu votre signature par exemple dans
des manifestes mais j'ai demandé à être
inculpé par la cour de surtout à l'état
ya passé donc s'essayer pas il ya dix
ans on ne demandait pas jaloux aucune
importance il ya dix ans alors vous
est-ce que vous votez maintenant oui je
n'ai pas voté pendant des années je lave
où je suis je
la politique pour moi c'est la vie je ne
me sens pas très proche de de la
politique politicienne je me sens très
déplacé et finalement ici je vais vous
déjà lu le livre de claude mauriac et
c'est vrai que notamment dans la
deuxième partie vous avez intitulé la
goutte d'or je me sens très très proche
de vous et c'est vrai que c'est un peu
viscérale chez moi aussi tout ça ça les
jeux je n'ai aucune ambition politique
évidemment je suis un humoriste mais la
politique c'est la vie dans la cité
n'est ce pas donc ça me regarde et je me
mêle des choses que je regarde aussi
j'en rends compte après non mais le
sketch ou dans les spectacles je peux
faire alors je le fais pour pour faire
rire mes reer de quoi rire de chose qui
existe est rien de quelle façon met à
rire peut-être
façon un peu vengeresse un peu
douloureuse sur les choses de la vie et
ces choses là sont aussi les choses de
ma vie je me sens concerné par ce qui
arrive aux autres aussi pour moi c'est
ça la politique ce n'est pas défendre sa
situation ou vouloir en acquérir une
notamment dans la politique et à vous
dit
la bataille du poste de poitiers vous
auriez été du côté des arabes
oui c'est vrai je vais je suis je suis
pieds noirs mais j'ai toujours été
favorable à l'algérie algérienne puis le
début vous me parlez de cette anecdote
brise la reconduite du mouvement de rien
mais c'est vrai que que je joue un bon
vous savez la politique cela m'a fait
aller sinon je préférerais qu'on achète
le livre qu'est ce qu'on fait là nos
éditeurs nous regarde
oui bon mais c'est vrai que le premier
gouvernement qu'on connaît c'est la
famille celle des parents et je me suis
sentie pas moi c'est comme ça que je me
suis sentie
un opposant très vite très tôt à ce
gouvernement là et pour moi ça a
commencé là notamment à propos de
l'algérie à propos du racisme
le racisme est pour moi le pivot un jeu
de mots de mon aïeule de mon engagement
politique
tout part de là et puis il ya les
racismes s'il n'y a pas que le racisme
de pau via lé racisme de classe bien sûr
s'étaient mêlés là-bas d'ailleurs très
souvent étrangement et puis maintenant
il ya les racismes de génération et
vieux déteste les jeunes gens détestent
les vieux souvent si vous passez
impressions du tout a vraiment pas chez
moi en quoi la jeune promise en tout cas
je vous ai trouvé très jeune chez moi
j'espère que ma famille n'est pas
terrorisé que je peux le gouvernement
comme vous le dites et tout d'un coup le
symbole
j'ai très peur tout d'un coup d'oeil
appelé trésor non mais moi je ne suis
pas le gouvernement pour ma fille non
vous ne pouvez plus maintenant non non
on a changé tout ça bon on a fait la
révolution
il ya là je vous propose vous propose
quelques thèmes qu'on retrouve dans 2-3
parfois quatre mines